i spent my whole life on earth battling
a stomachache because i never knew what
to do and for a while here that was gone
but recently
i've been miserable why chidi you're in
the good place i know but i i have this
problem and
if i choose option a
but if i choose option b
oh no
you know chidi
sometimes adversity can lead to growth
whatever the moral dilemma is maybe
you'll come out on the other side better
for it
yeah
no
i'm i'm used to moral dilemmas i like
moral dilemmas they're my jam but this
just feels like i'm
what like i'm being punished somehow and
obviously i know that's silly this is
the good place you two would never do
anything to hurt anyone but i am
seriously worried that i did something
wrong
and this is the universe getting back at
me
oh no
wow wait what's what's happening now oh
no no no no no no i i made god cry
i hate this
and i'm sorry
and did i did i say that i hate this
because i hate this you don't need to
apologize for making a huge sacrifice to
save your friends
this is why people love moral philosophy
professors
how about
this every time you see me get a
stomachache
imagine i'm thinking of you so
all the time exactly
sorry to interrupt
i wanted to give both of you something
before we do this think of it as a going
away present
[Music]
bye
[Music]
i don't normally cry at movies
but that one was pretty good
that girl was hot
like i was too
i was never good at being sad
partly because my mom straight-up told
me not to be
but this is sad man
you got a john locke quote or a
piece of county and wisdom you can throw
at me
those guys were more focused on rules
and
regulations for spiritual stuff
you gotta turn to the east
i'll take anything you got hit me
[Music]
picture a wave
in the ocean
now you can see it measure it its height
the way the
sunlight refracts when it passes through
and
it's there and you can see it you know
what it is it's a wave
and then he crashes on the shore
and it's gone
but the water
is still there
the wave was just a
different way for the water to be
for a little while
that's one conception of death for a
buddhist
the wave
returns to the ocean
[Music]
where it came from
and where it's supposed to be
not bad buddhists not bad
none of this is bad
i need you to do me one last favor
[Music]
say goodbye to me now
and leave before i wake up
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey mike where are you headed today
earth
actually oh
it's been a while
is the return quicker no need
one-way trip
wow
okay
good luck
thank you
i have something for you mm-hmm
he's real
it's real he's a real frog yes it sure
is
thank you
you know what
i got the perfect name for him
mr jumpy legs
oh
i thought you were gonna never mind
hello mr jumpy legs
okay
so here's your driver's license and your
social security card
i set up a bank account for you there's
enough money in there so that you don't
starve but not so much that you become
an entitled jerk
thank you make a doctor's appointment as
soon as you get down there and no salty
food you have to keep your blood
pressure down you have blood now
i'll be fine
i'll be okay i know i just worry
i'll see you again you know
i'll see you when i get back
[Music]
if you rent a car don't pay for the
insurance it's a scam
okay
[Music]
oh man it's hot
but it's a it's a dry heat
some good days
some bad days
she's gonna be okay
the city has some really good hospitals
he's got a few friends such a good boy
jason such a good boy
a few people he can't stand
[Music]
he's learning some things all by himself
[Music]
and hopefully learning to ask for help
when he needs it
turn like this fingers this way
[Music]
you have no idea how long i've been
trying to figure that out
well everybody needs a teacher
so do it again he's messing up and
trying again and messing up again and
then getting things wrong and then
trying to make them right
you